you uh
you thought the cast of Avengers end
game was big
[Music]
hey folks I'm gonna talk about something
I've wanted to talk about for a while
but have had no reason to do so and now
I'm just gonna say to hell with it and
just do it
um
I have been playing the same
color matching game you know three of
the same color match them together they
clear away I've been playing the same
one of those for almost eight years
and I kind of want to talk about the ins
and outses that how that happened
and as we go through this I'm going to
tell you why Marvel Puzzle Quest
is awesome and also why you definitely
should not get into it and shouldn't
play it
so maybe a little background on me I am
old enough and have had a smartphone for
long enough to remember when mobile
games
were actually interesting and good I
remember the first Angry Birds I
remember Cut the Rope I remember when
these things were fresh and new and they
were actually fairly complete
experiences that you could get some were
free some you paid a couple of bucks for
but they weren't all identical variants
of the exact same thing even within like
you know color matching things you had
Bejeweled yet Candy Crush that was kind
of the big one for a while you add these
various things of that nature
and I played a fair a number of them as
time went on Candy Crush I stuck with
for a while but over time that and a
bunch of others that I don't even
remember the names of now I bounced off
of over time
I never did bounce off Marvel Puzzle
Quest though once I found it
and it's kind of fascinating to think
about why
what is it about this game that keeps me
coming back because in the World of
Color matching games it's honestly
pretty well designed and if you're a
Marvel fan absolute bonus you don't even
have to be that deep of a fan despite
how deep some of the cuts in this are
but at the same time
yeah it's it's not
good like it's good for what it is but
what it is is kind of bad
how do I want to go through this well
why don't we talk about some of the
reasons why I tended to bounce off other
games so to use Candy Crush as a prime
example because it kind of was the
template from which all sorts of things
spawned by and large as you work your
way through that you got only so many
chances uh before you would basically
run out of opportunities you had like a
certain number of lives and every
failure took a life so you would find
yourself stuck on the exact same
um you know area the exact same puzzle
the exact same board for ages because it
was a tricky one and
um you would only get like five chances
to beat it in a day and then you'd have
to wait for things to recharge and it
could take a few hours or depending on
how the game was structured it could be
the next day you had to come back and
all of that was designed to frustrate
you into spending money and I refused to
spend money on those games and as a
result all of them I bounced off of
eventually eventually whatever fun I was
having from the color matching and it
tended to be pretty limited like match
three they go away match four maybe it
clears a column or a row uh match more
than that maybe you'll get a bigger
effect or you know maybe those be some
items that are limited and you can buy
more
um use those to like have certain
effects but
the novelty would wear off pretty
quickly
yet I stuck with Marvel Puzzle Quest
and
strictly speaking it also has a live
system your various characters that you
control because you set up a lineup of
three characters for any given uh match
it is both PVP and PVE and you get your
lineup and they will take damage as this
goes now that damage will recover on its
own over time but if you want to repair
it all instantly that'll cost you a
health token and you get 10 of those a
day and when I say 10 I mean once it
hits 10 it stops recharging further but
if it's anything less than 10 they
slowly recharge over time it's a little
bit less than a half hour to get one
back so on paper it is using the same
kind of system that frustrated me out of
these other games so what's the
difference
well
strictly speaking if you run out of
Health
it doesn't stop you being able to play
the game
it just means you can't heal up whatever
current characters might be knocked out
or might be at a low enough percentage
of their health that it's not worth
trying to get through a match with them
but they're not the only ones you've got
so while it might cause you to rethink
your play style and reformat your team
and take a different approach from maybe
what is your ideal or your Optimizer
your preferred
you can actually keep playing and so the
natural question that follows is well
how many characters are there I mean
obviously at some point you have to run
out well
depends on how long you've been playing
this is one of the first reasons why I'm
gonna tell you you should not start
playing this game if you don't play it
already I have every single character
banked most of them championed ah crap I
gotta explain that so um every character
has three different skills that they
have and you can bring those up and you
as you go up and get more of them
because obviously this is the kind of
game that has randomized elements they
are effectively loot boxes where you get
um certain covers and certain abilities
and once they get to level 13 meaning
you've gotten a version of them 13 times
from a pack you can then set them to
Champion in which case you can adjust
their abilities because you get 13
points to distribute through three
abilities with a cap of five so you can
set two abilities at the maximum a level
of five and one out of three if it's an
ability you don't think you'll use much
or you can set one to a five and two to
Fours if you want to go for a more even
distribution or the nature of the
abilities that character has have that
make more sense
but anyway coming back to my original
statement I have at time of recording
every available character currently in
my roster and most of them are
championed the main list of ones that I
haven't championed yet are my five star
characters a number of whom I could but
it takes a lot of the uh ISO 8 which is
one of the numerous currencies that one
used to level up because yeah of course
there's another reason never to get into
this game it also pulls the multiple
currency thing there is the iso 8 which
is used for leveling up there is red
isolate which is used for leveling up
um your support uh items and those are a
whole other thing I'll touch on the
supports real briefly what I like about
them is you can't actually use them in
PvP you can only use them in PVE which
is good because in PvP they could
completely unbalance the whole thing so
they are really just a nice for fun
thing and I kind of like that and uh red
ISO 8 you actually can't buy some of
these
um you can buy directly they do that
thing where if you spend a lot actually
you get bonus stuff and some of the
other currency but I'm not going to
delve into a deep look at the currency
system because It suffers from much of
the fury that most of these mobile games
uh have suffered from for years
but while you can buy some of these
currencies every single currency can not
only be earned in game but it can also
be earned at a pretty decent pace
assuming you have a fully rostered
lineup which again I only have because
I've been playing this thing for eight
damn years I have no clue how long it
would take somebody starting from
scratch to to be at the level that I'm
at it will be a damn long time and it
would encourage you to spend money which
is why I'm telling you if you don't
already play this game don't get into it
I I'm not gonna say I've never spent
money in this game I have spent some I
spent I think a total of 60 bucks within
the first three months of playing it and
then they changed the one mechanic that
was enough to get me to buy the currency
that was being sold so what used to
happen
because amongst the many things you have
to unlock when you've rostered a new
character or at least you get the card
so that you could roster a new character
you also have to have a slot available
you have to buy the slots not with real
money directly but with the currency
that you can buy with real money
and what used to be the case and this
has not been the case for usable what
used to be the case and this was the one
thing that got me to spend money and I'm
a little bit resentful about it but what
used to happen is once you had a uh a
cover for a character one of the cards
for a character for one you didn't
already have
if you did not get that added to your
roster I.E open up a slot I.E buy a slot
they would only kind of sit in Waiting
for a limited amount of time I think it
was a week might have been less and so
what that meant was you were either
scrambling trying to earn enough of the
currency through the normaling game uh
methods so that you could buy more slots
or you just spent real money to open up
the slots otherwise you were at risk of
the character dying on the vine before
you could actually add it to your roster
this was the one predatory mechanic that
did actually get to me a little bit and
if it had never been gotten rid of I
would have had to have bailed on the
game because I'm honestly okay with the
60 bucks that I've spent uh on the game
out to this point that's the cost of a
brand new game in most circumstances and
most games have not given me eight years
worth of play time so you know it's not
continuous play time but still so I'm
okay with it but if they kept that
mechanic again I would have had to have
quit the game that was the one thing
that hooked me in
that having been said I uh and my own
particular neurodivergencies line up in
such a way that the mechanics that
remain
don't get to me I'm actually very good
at ignoring them and again part of it
helps that I am so far progressed in the
game that the only way that I would want
to be spending money for more advantages
or to level other things up faster or
whatever
would be if I was really into the PVP
but I'm not I do it
um but it's not the primary thing I'm
there for it's not what I spend a lot of
time doing if you're very heavy into the
PVP then a lot of the tactics are going
to be more effective on you and also if
you don't
just have the resources that I've had
because there are over 300 characters in
this and trying to get them all rostered
in anything that feels close to a
reasonable amount of time you are going
to be tempted to spend money and I know
it works because I'm also in an alliance
it's their equivalent of a guild and one
of the things that happens if is if you
spend a certain amount of money you get
a certain amount of sort of bonus of
this extra currency the name of which I
suddenly can't remember all of a sudden
it's like Shield points I can't remember
but I know what they are I know them
visually I just can't remember the name
you'd think I should know this stuff
playing it for as long as I did but
regardless if you buy enough to get a
certain extra amount of those the other
people in your alliance also get them
so that's how I know these tricks work
is because it's not super uncommon for
me to open up the game and get these
bonus points because other members of my
alliance have spent anywhere from 10 to
a hundred dollars and that's how I know
that while the remaining tricks after
they got rid of the timer may not be
working on me
but I know they work on other people
another reason you should not buy this
game I say buy it's free to play you
should not play this game
you really shouldn't
but I have been
and now
we're going to talk about the ins and
outs of
why I love it
the first thing is that there is
actually legitimate strategy to this
game at this point I've got enough
Champion stuff and enough kind of very
high level Elite kind of things that
when it goes through the various story
modes that kind of reset daily I can
trounce most of what's in my way at this
point but that's just where I'm at
getting here felt like a victory because
I had to actually think about what I was
doing here's what's really fun I
mentioned already the characters
different powers and those Powers range
from all manner of things a lot of them
involve some form of damage dealing
either to a single Target or to the
entire enemy team some of them will
destroy certain kinds of blocks some of
them will turn various blocks into a
certain color and maybe that will either
help this particular character or
another character on their team if they
have an ability that's powered up by
that color some of them have the ability
to stun their enemies there are various
special tiles that you can get attack
tiles strike tiles defense tiles to
either make you take less damage deal
more damage or do additional hits per
round on the opposing team and some of
the abilities are incredibly
straightforward just hit for damage some
are healing some are defensive some can
actually turn characters invisible for
either a set amount of time or for as
long as a certain special tile remains
on the board all of these things can be
taken into account not only for your own
team but against the teams you're facing
now in the story mode a lot of the
things that you're going to work your
way through are just kind of generic
things you know you're fighting aim
scientists or soldiers or Ultron Bots
though actually those are they're kind
of a pain in the ass
but uh it's that kind of thing symbiote
spawn Etc and you know you work your way
through those at high levels those can
also be damaging and that's another
thing it doesn't automatically scale up
difficulty you actually choose your
difficulty level I play at Max
difficulty level when I play the PVE but
that's because of the kind of resources
I have you go at a lower level so that
you can still get as much of the rewards
for playing that day as possible because
yes it does the daily rewards thing but
also actually flat out rewards you for
playing you get rewarded with tokens to
open new packs and of course you can get
tokens open Legendary Packs or heroic
packs or Elite packs or Mighty packs and
you know it's all this sort of stuff
that is honestly at this point if you
were again if you were to start playing
right now probably overwhelming probably
too many options I'm very used to it
because a lot of this stuff was added
over time I say new I mean new to me
I've been playing this thing for dang
near eight years and it's been around
for I think 10 now they had like a big
10-year anniversary thing this year so
I've been playing it not as long as it's
been around but pretty close but that
added strategy that you the abilities
that your characters have they build up
as you eliminate certain colored blocks
you earn those blocks as kind of a
reserve so if you match three green that
UPS your number of green points by three
and maybe you've got say one of the
versions of Thor that has a green
ability that can be set off with 12
green points or something like that and
so the strategy comes not only in
matching things and getting as much
cleared as possible because it has the
standard match 4 clears the whole row or
column or whatever and that sort of
thing but also getting the things that
you need so that you can actually set
off your abilities and it's not just a
matter of set it off as soon as it's
ready although they're adding in a new
feature to set it so it does
automatically fire as soon as it's ready
which I I will never use because there
are some abilities that are just going
to work much better as a follow-up to
something else maybe you want to stun
the team before you hit them with this
thing especially if they've got a Healer
on their team so you know they're not
going to heal up immediately right away
and then there's just all these ways
that various characters complement each
other their abilities to complement each
other directly you often need a full
team to have all the colors doing
something in some form there's passive
abilities that aren't activated but will
automatically happen when certain
conditions are met either when certain
things are done by allies when certain
things are done by enemies or when you
acquire a certain amount of this or that
color or what have you certain
conditions will set off something that
they do automatically but they're
specifically built to work that way
America Chavez works that way and she's
great that's the thing pretty much all
of these characters are workable and
viable like some of the very low level
ones aren't terrific they aren't but
it's because they're very low level but
even at the level ones you get them up
to the max level they can get and if you
know what you're doing you can still
work your way through the game to the
point where you start getting the two
star then you start getting the three
star and to keep working your way
through
these are all useful and more than that
they can all be fun to learn and fun to
know how to beat to play against to be
satisfying to defeat like there really
is no character that feels like this
just is well okay actually that's not
true there's one it's Chasm who I hate
you don't run into him in PVE but a lot
of folks use him in PvP and I cannot
stand him he is neither fun to play with
nor to play against and he's damn near
impossible to kill but he makes the game
boring I hate him I actually don't know
anything about that character I know
it's something that they're doing with
Ben Reilly now but I only know that
because of this game but I hate him no
matter how good he is in the comics
because wow is he busted he's too good
to not use but he makes the game
terrible but that one specific balance
issue aside pretty much everything that
there is can be countered by something
else and that's actually you can tell
oftentimes sort of the design Mythos if
there's a character that has been being
favored a lot especially in the PVP then
there'll be a new character introduced
that will have something that not the
entire character will be set to offset
what they did but makes it easier to
counteract them and to work on the
balance the balancing with the new
characters is fairly continual if
there's a downside to this I do think
they've started introducing newer stuff
too quickly it
I wasn't keeping track but it really
felt like it used to be every couple of
months that a new character would be
introduced but these days it's like once
a month minimum and sometimes I think
it's even more frequent than that and
honestly I think it's too much and I
don't mean in terms of they're running
out of characters they're coming up with
some fun characters to do I'll get into
some of that in a little bit but I mean
it much more in the sense of well the
most straightforward abilities have been
covered for years and even some of the
more elaborate abilities like oh you do
this and it causes this and that and
like that's cool some of the newer
characters their abilities are so it's
so terrigan they take so long to explain
that like I barely use them not because
they're not good but because
they're just exhausting for me to use I
keep forgetting because their abilities
are not straightforward at all and then
I have to reread the ability every time
I'm like I'm just going to play with
somebody who I know what they do give me
my five star Kitty Pride back on this
team I know how she works this is
confusing and unfortunately that's kind
of a natural progression as the game has
more and more and more characters that
over time as it goes well the
straightforward stuff's all been
accounted for So to avoid power creep in
the sense of well this one just does the
same thing other ones do but harder and
do and does more damage they actually do
try and comment that by coming up with
newer ways for things to work and props
to them for that but at the same time it
does mean that the abilities are getting
a little odd and yes every now and then
we have massive power creep issues Chasm
is the big one uh Immortal Hulk also
kind of an issue those two together
especially paired with Immortal She-Hulk
is actually a big go-to PVP team right
now and I again I hate it and it's
boring to try and play against it's not
even that much fun to play as but
regardless my beef with Chasm aside I
actually really like how deep some of
the cuts are for this because as I said
there's over 300 characters in this now
don't make the mistake of thinking
there's 300 unique characters there's a
lot of duplicates there is say with
someone like Spider-Man there's a one
star Spider-Man there's a two star a
three star there's a couple of four star
Spider-Mans there's at least two
five-star Spider-Mans there's some
repeats in here and sometimes it makes
sense and sometimes it's very
straightforward like take Thor so he has
a two star version of three starboard he
actually has more than that but just to
use as an example his two star in his
three-star version just have the exact
same abilities just does them harder in
the three star version sometimes you get
that uh with some of the things that
have been introduced but other times it
is retooled to fit an actual different
variant of the characters like Emma
Frost who started out as as a four-star
character she had later on got a three
star version and a five-star version but
what's cool here is that the five-star
version is actually the version of her
possessed by the Phoenix Force so
there's actually justification for why
her abilities are different and I
suppose I should get into the characters
so I'm actually at this point very used
to almost more used to seeing their uh
comic book covers that get shown in the
roster I mean I see them in the uh when
they go head to head against enemies but
I don't pay a lot of attention to that
if I'm honest and while I turn them back
on to get b-roll for this I don't
actually make use of the character
effects very much I've seen most of them
before and they do slow the game down
and this is a game that I very much play
when I'm doing something else but it's
not occupying my whole time so like I'm
listening to a podcast but I want to do
something with my hands that kind of
thing and it's really great for that and
as someone with ADHD it takes just
enough of my attention that I feel
properly like occupied in my mind isn't
restless but it doesn't take so much of
my attention that I completely lose
track of something else provided that
other thing isn't super over complicated
again podcast is a great example but
there's some interesting quirks in terms
of the way the uh specific portraits for
this game are
um some of them whether there is a
corresponding cover with this design or
not some of them are very clearly far
more influenced by the movie versions
and actually that used to be the
reliable thing for timing of when new
stuff would come out because characters
like say killmonger and shuri came out
in association with the release of the
first black panther and nomura got
released in association with uh the
second Black Panther movie and you can
very much tell that regardless of what
the comic book cover that's there is the
reference in the roster you can tell
that their design is influenced by the
movies and then sometimes you get the
occasional odd bit where the uh comic
book version of the character is
stylized to the point that trying to
make them fit the artistic style of the
rest of the game kind of results in
something horrific unfortunately
Squirrel Girl suffers from that a fair
bit which is a real shame because I like
Squirrel Girl a lot she's even a decent
uh three star card when you're at that
point in the game I haven't played her
in ages but I almost never play three
star cards anymore other than certain
events that require me to and even then
she's generally not in my lineup if I'm
gonna go three star I'm gonna go three
star black panther three-star Deadpool
three star Kamala Khan because then I
have three different options for whole
team hit oh three star Deadpool let's
stop and talk about him for a hot second
this is another really cool thing and it
kind of serves as an emergency you
option because three-star Deadpool if
you play with him daily he kind of has
his own little point system that gets
built up day by day and I'm rounding up
here but about every 10 days or so you
get enough uh points accumulated to be
able to use the super powered version of
his whale drop move I forget what it's
actually called and you can choose that
option and if you do that is a full team
Wipeout you win if you activate that now
as I said you've got to play with him
daily it takes about 10 days to store up
enough to even be able to use it once so
it's not something that you can just
Spam and more to the point it takes 14
purple tiles to be able to get him
powered up enough to use it and if
you're in a fight where the only way
you're gonna win is getting him to fire
that then actually having him survive
long enough to get all of the purples
that you need to fire it is at times no
small feat so while it is a little bit
of a cheat it's not one you can spam
it's one you still have to earn the
ability to use in-game and to be honest
I still use it even at the level I'm at
I will still get into situations I
generally don't use it in PvP but even
in some of the things I get into with
some of the PVE I will get annoyed
enough at it and want the reward for
that particular fight that I will just
go screw it I will wipe you out with
Deadpool and you know what it doesn't
feel like a cheat it feels cathartic it
feels like me just going okay
I'm just done with you you're gone now
and it's fun and there's other little
aspects of the strategy like in the PVP
you're not actually playing another
player live they set up their team and
they go after people you set up your
team you go after people but when you
play against another player in PvP their
team is controlled by the AI so it
behaves predictably you'll learn as you
go there are certain things you can
count on the AI to do when the board is
laid out in certain ways and that can
actually be one more thing that adds to
the strategy and makes it more than just
match the colors you know what I've
mentioned the roster more than a few
times you're probably wondering who's on
it you know what let's do this
Abigail brand Abomination Adam Warlock
Agent Coulson America Chavez Ant-Man
anti-venom Aries Beta Ray Bill Black Cat
Black Knight Chasm Cleo Colleen Wayne
Cosmo deathlock devil dinosaur Echo
Electro Elsa Bloodstone gargantos
Gertrude York's ghost Green Goblin
gwenpool Hellcat Howard the Duck
hulkling Invisible Woman Jessica Jones
Kate Bishop killmonger no craving the
hunter lizard umbaku Marie Hill Melinda
May Mr negative Misty night Mockingbird
Modoc Monica Rambo Moonstone it's morbin
time mordo Mr Fantastic Mysterio Namor
namora Nick Fury North Star Nova Okoye
Peggy Carter Prowler Puck Red Guardian
Red Hulk Reptil rescue Rhino Ronin
Sandman scorpion Century Xiang Chi shuri
silver Knight Squirrel Girl Super
Squirrel Talos Taskmaster the hood the
hydrostomper the thing throg Ultron
venomous Rex Vision War Machine Winter
Soldier Wang and yellow jacket and
that's just the one there's only one
version of there are two versions of
arcade two versions of Beast two blades
two bullseyes two carnages two colossi
either two or three Dawkins depending on
how you count them two Daredevils two
doctor Dooms two Doctor Strange's two
gambits two Ghost Riders to a high
evolutionaries two hitmont monkeys two
Ice Men two Iron Fist two Jean Gray two
versions of Jeffrey the shark two
juggernauts two kamalakons two kangs two
kingpins two kitty Prides two Luke cages
two moon Knights two Omega Reds two
Professor X's two Riri Williams's
two versions of rock and a Groot
together as a pair two Sam Wilson's two
Scarlet witches two punishers two
iterations of the Jane Foster version of
Thor two wasps two Elena bulovas three
black panthers three Cyclops with three
Deadpools three doctor octopi three
electros three Emma Frost three gamoras
three Loki's three Magics three magnetos
three she-hulks three spider gwens three
star-lords three thanos's is three Thor
Classics three Venoms three vultures
four Captain Marvel's four human torches
four Iron Men Four storms five black
widows five Captain America's five
Hawkeyes five versions of the Hulk if we
lump in totally awesome Hulk if not then
there's four versions of the Bruce
Banner and one Amadeus Cho either five
or four Wolverines depending on how you
count them seven versions of Spider-Man
and that's only counting the ones that
are actually some incarnation of Peter
Parker that's not counting the ones that
are not Peter Parker but still hold a
similar title such as Penny Parker Miles
Morales Spider-Man 2099 Spider Woman
silk spider Rex and spider ham and aside
from what I've specifically named there
are six as guardian or as guardian
related characters two eternals five
miscellaneous Guardians of the Galaxy
six Inhumans 30 miscellaneous mutants
and to top it all off big wheel as a
five star huh
so yeah
there's a lot to this game and they keep
adding more and for me who's been
playing it for a long time that can be a
good thing because it gives me more
things to do to acquire I've still got a
lot of leveling up to do for these
characters
but add it to the amount of reasons why
I don't recommend anyone start playing
it because
they're adding more stuff that's great
for me who's exhausted all the lower
level stuff but for someone new to come
in to see how much there is to gather to
know how long it will take if you don't
spend money
I don't recommend anybody jump into that
environment
but I I do love this game I really love
this game I have been playing it for
years and I don't intend to stop
I'm still having fun with this
and I am also the kind of person who
just needs a go-to like I've got a few
minutes my brain needs to be occupied I
can play this or I can't
um folk I have something I need to do I
can't focus on it completely I need
something to do with my hands oh I can
play this I need something to fill that
role
and Marvel Puzzle Quest has done it
better than anything else I've ever had
and lasted longer doing it everything
else that I've ever used to fill that
kind of Niche I've bounced off of
eventually over time no matter what it
was whether it was this whether it was
Sudoku whether it was Wordle whether it
was Words With Friends whatever
but this
no I'm uh I'm probably with this one for
as long as they keep doing it
provided that they don't manage to shift
to the monetization to a model that
actually makes me tempted to buy again
because then I might have to bounce and
if that does happen
uh I hope they realize how long and
devoted a player they will be losing
but that's Marvel Puzzle Quest
it's a game that I love
and you should not play
have you ever played Marvel Puzzle Quest
if not what did you think about what I
said about it if you have
what's your favorite team I mean my
go-to's and they have been for a while
granted I play mostly PVE is a five-star
Kitty Pride Polaris and four-star Rocket
and Groot it's an easy go-to uh that's
when I'm dealing with some of the higher
end actually the lower end stuff replace
uh five-star Kitty Pride with four star
Juggernaut and you just wipe them out in
one or two turns uh to clear the low
level stuff while you do in story mode I
found myself using Mighty Thor an awful
lot too she's a just a fantastic go-to
she slots into so many teams really
really well but what are your thoughts
what do you play with what do you think
of what I've described what do you think
I had the roster lineup whatever your
thoughts are
for this mess that I have described and
that I continue to sink time into
dropping down in the comments let's talk
about patreon pays the bills enables me
to do this as my living where I
sometimes do
this nonsense apparently
but uh don't worry too much about it
there's other stuff that I do down in
the description you can check out but
ultimately
what I want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid and you are loved
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
foreign
shout out to the patrons who helped make
this possible in particular I want to
thank Robin Moore Zubin fulla goddess
Elida Tarak the thing that goes joint in
the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen auntie
kate808 Becky Sparks ranabilox the
poodle Robin Powell t love Tracy scrap
it Angry Casper Dave Hall and Rosalind
Bennett there's being able to hear me
try and pronounce your name plus a whole
bunch of other rewards on the patreon
you can check out the tears but um
if you're already on the list thank you
so much
[Music]
foreign